majeur et c'est un signal très positif
envoyé à tous les chefs d'entreprises et
notamment aux toutes petites TPE qui
sont notre maillage économique et sur
lesquels on sait qu'elles peuvent
recruter massivement pourquoi est-ce que
le taux d'emploi des seniors aussi fait
en France d'abord je pense qu'il y a une
raison culturelle culturellement par
rapport à d'autres pays on considère
qu'à un certain âge quand on despages
les 50 50 on est plus utile dans la
feuilletée ou on est moins utile ou on
coûte trop cher l'intérêt d'avoir des
seigneurs des entreprises c'est quand
même la transmission c'est la transition
et une valeur travail partagée avec une
connaissance de personnes qui sont
investies pendant tout d'une vie toute
une carrière et qui peuvent transmettre
à des jeunes leur savoir leur technique
et ça fait gagner du temps tout
simplement à l'entreprise c'est c'est
vers cela qu'on doit aller c'est très
culturel mais il faut qu'il faut un
accompagnement évidemment social à
travers nos mesures et économiques